ah
don't think so hey you got your brother
right here
I wanted to call you because
um I have a crush on you
oh okay
I mean he's not Matthew right here oh
whoa the cringe went I didn't like I
didn't hear the last part because the
cringe was too high she said oh
okay
you've met Matthew right
yeah
ah I thought the prince was bad and this
is all taba Magnus Scott Elizabeth is
see oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] and Matthew probably
standing across her right now
he doesn't have to Matthew's her
boyfriend I need dick in her down good
she said listen Raj Kumar uh
I don't need any I.T help we good yeah
yeah your boyfriend yeah ah you knew
is this wet
this was
a dumpster fire in a car crash in a
train wreck all right you knew here we
go hey this ladies ladies this this is
some of your male friends
this is how they feel about you this
friends could do better you know what I
call them hyenas and waiting
do you know why I said hyena
because a hyena waits till You're
vulnerable yeah that's the only time
they attack in packs and they wait till
they have the advantage hey they show a
little cry on becomes a dick to ride on
that's right hyenas sometimes hang
around lines and just wait for them to
have scraps and then try to take what
they can scavengers yeah yeah that's you
you the piece of meat hello hi what is
up
do you find me attractive
yes I do okay
um imagine someone calls you and ask you
that just randomly
yes that yes yes yes yes yes yep yep
that no no yeah that that's
that answers my question
yeah
you miss having that knowing you just
gotta walk 20 steps to get the water but
you're like beside leaving this room let
me just dehydrate
turn monitor into the Sahara Desert
because my ass is lazy to get some much
needed water
a 2022 problem yeah yeah
yeah yeah first world issues I'm so
thirsty walk 10 steps
I have to be on Tick Tock do you find me
attractive
aggressively
I find you attractive Oh Aaron
personally
yeah yes
wow yeah I have feelings for you I just
wanted you to know
you're crazy though
[Laughter]
I appreciate you by the way are you the
way she's out the way she left I know
she knew all right bye have a good day
bye Jake oh my God
[Music]
ah I'm like shaking I want you to call
your crush and ask you to find me
attractive
um
are you crushing on anyone who you
crushing on um a friend of mine it's
leopard girl the cougar
yes
well this is going well
yes yes this is one girl who 150 sucks
dick with enthusiasm friend do they know
how you feel uh no call your crush and
ask if they find you attractive
let's do it okay I feel like every dude
has got a loaf on his head it's got to
be gay
hello what with the loaf on the head
they gotta be gay like nobody cops that
haircut and it is not good it's the same
way like every dude's got that like
low fade on the side Mushroom on the top
is a [ __ ] boy the loaf on the head is
for gay [ __ ]
huh
just to catch all the semen or whatever
hey yo
hey
um hey yeah I can hear you
um I just wanted to call and tell you
that I love you I just called
um I have a crush on you and just
wondering are you attracted to me
I don't think so
Oh no just wanted to call and let you
know that I think you're an amazing
person and I've Loved getting to know
you and I think you're really cute
and I might have feelings for you
[Music]
that's okay I'm glad that we established
this
yo
I got
[Music]
[Music]
thank you oh
I'm gonna tell you one thing all right
lady lady I don't know I look I don't
know if you still with us on this planet
anymore uh all that copium you trying to
inhale is not gonna be enough uh but I
appreciate how well you took that
exactly I tried my girl my girl imma
talk to you my girl my girl I like you
my girl I don't even know you
you my homie forever cause the way you
could take that l
the way you take that l
is the kind of people I want in my life
to take else the way you took that wow
you took that L as well as you would
want to take that dick you took it so
well
that's okay I'm glad we got established
that good that's how you should say
whoa
okay I took back everything I just said
everything I just said right in the
[ __ ] field I'm sorry
but okay it's still good the way you
handled it you handled it but say that
to your co-worker
Auntie uh on YouTube in front of that
that's kind of but we don't know who he
is but that's [ __ ] the people aren't
working on now yo so that's awkward oh
yeah just saying oh rumors go what but
you think I did we put another video so
if they haven't watched yet they're
gonna watch it soon I'm just saying
but hey you kind of wild for that lady
but but but you the way you took it yeah
yeah be gentle but what do you what do
you rate my attractiveness
well on a scale of one to frog
that's bad
oh that's ouch seven
so like I was saying on a scale of one
to frog
I'm just sorry it just annoys the [ __ ]
out of me not like
it's like you average it's okay
he gave you a generous ass score of
7.7.5 Kevin you're generous
is that you man man
I'm gonna need you to stop it man your
average
I'm just saying it's okay you're like
can I ask y'all a question go ahead
what the [ __ ] is wrong with being
average I mean at some point when I was
in school I was not doing so good
[Music]
I couldn't get 90s
I couldn't get hundreds the 80d was off
the roof it was crazy but it was not
diagnosed because it didn't exist at
that time
and sometimes I hit a test and I had 75.
I'm not failing
it's average
and I was happy to that's what I could
do listen I studied I never missed a
[ __ ] day
I was there for the whole explanation I
studied at night then I lost some sleep
in other words this test I showed up I
showed up before the test early so I
could review my notes I go to the test I
passed the grit I did all my [ __ ] I got
75.
I've been my best
that's the best you're gonna get out of
me and what's wrong with that
sometimes average is good to be fair
7.5 is above average
on top of that
I'm just saying
[ __ ] come say preach
you were six I'm gonna be like [ __ ] I
didn't ask but thank you very much have
you considered like dating me
no have you ever had maybe possibly
similar
feelings
um about me
I can honest
[Applause]
ly yeah yeah
after you know a sister I want to [ __ ]
how do you feel about incest [ __ ]
because
keeping in the families how you keep it
strong you know what they say
blood is thicker than water and semen is
thicker than all three so what's up baby
you have to say hey let's go let's go
what all three what do you think I meant
uh listen incest we don't know how to
count [ __ ] let's get this that's crazy
but that's good I'm gonna have to give
it to you I mean you know what they say
right let it stick in the water
sticking at both
bars technical glass at all three that's
a double entender incest part
IES because incest people bro yeah
listen listen listen listen they say A
Mother's love knows no bounds but can a
mother give you this dick
don't think so hey you got your brother
right here
my favorite meme on the internet
incestors incest yeah that's a good one
that's a good one I like that one how
did that feel uh I felt like I got
something off of my chest do you feel
like rejected
um a little bit I feel I mean I've
definitely felt a little sting it just
kind of like went off the rails which is
like my love history for sure I want you
to call your crush and ask them do you
find me attractive
are you single yes
notoriously I remember that girl she who
shall not be rejected yes yes she always
wins you can't ever get rejected if you
kill them before they can say no
hands I ain't get out with it now
[Music]
I was just wondering you know truly like
truly not like what you're supposed to
say do you find me attractive yes
that's it that's it that's it I don't
you can't give me more
details yes I agree
yes I agree
do you that's a yes no you got the yes
you're not happy with that
[ __ ]
um I was just calling to let you know
that I have a crush on you and I think
that you are really cute and was
wondering if you also liked me or have
feelings for me I'm literally and I like
you too and I think you're really cute
oh thank you I'm calling to let you know
that I have a crush on you
uh and I was I was wondering if you find
me attractive as well well with those
[Music]
I've seen you dancing bachata
with those Machado skills I gotta give
you this dick
why are we [ __ ] I'ma play some bad
bunny in the background
[ __ ] makes the [ __ ]
that's not the same thing Hey listen
listen you don't give a [ __ ] I know I
don't you hate both will you go on a
date with me tonight yeah
okay
well I'll set something up then well we
should plan something for this week
but do you want to go out when you're
back in town
[Music]
um I'm Gonna Let You Go uh but we can
talk later if that's okay
okay cool I'll talk to you most can only
end terribly uh dating dancers from out
of town just means that they are the
Danes and [ __ ] you and then disappear
get ready for some disappointment
because if you like your Bachata skills
let me tell you he saw a lot of other
girls Bachata skills at socials I
believe we called Dick's appointment oh
yeah oh yeah listen the dance scene is
fraught with a little bit of [ __ ] do
you feel me a little bit of [ __ ] in
my life well there you go people took
rejection really well other people had
some success it was cool tomorrow's a
story girls speak up
yeah can end well again and if it don't
welcome to life there you have it let us
know what you guys think in the comments
and if you guys are enjoying today's
video be sure to like comment you
already know how YouTube dealing with us
you know what I mean hiding our stuff
sometimes you can help us out by just
putting it out in the algorithm like
comment do that regularly hit that bell
all that good stuff and subscribe